(cris des partisans)
- Avant-match États-Unis-Iran;
une rencontre cruc
qui va au-delà du sport.
(son de tr
Répression en Iran, drapeaux
ststststiniens, soutien à
la communauté LGBT brimée...
(en anglais)
La gtitititique et les
préoccupations sociales
s'invitent sur le terrain
(en anglais)
Si l
sont tolérés par l'organisation
qatarie, bon nombre
de spectateurs découvrent
les restrictions à la liberté
Coupe du monde.
Saeed Kamalinia a réussi e e e l
"Femme, Vie, Liberté" en appui
à la révolte contre le ré
Il le portait comme
sous-vêtement pour déjouer
la sécurité à l'entrée du stade.
Saeed et ses amis ont ét i i i s
par les autorités qataries
pendant quatre heures
à leur sortie du match.
Soudainement, des gardiens
pendant l'entrevue avec Saeed,m.
et lécher son image, le Qatar
interde e e e e e d'images
presque partout sauf
sur les sites de la FIFA.
d'expression ont pris plusieurs
s s s s s s spectateurs
ont dû retirer leur chandail
et même leur montre aux couleur
qui s'apparentait à du soutien
pour la communauté LGBT était
interdit. La FIFA est intervenue
ces messages d'appui soient
dorénavant tolérés.
Un homme avec un drapeau
arc-en-ciel et un message
contre la répression en Iran
a d'ailleurs sauté
sur le terrain, lundi.
Saeed, lui, a assistéx x x x xs
au Brésil et en Russ
Il affirme que ces pays avaient
fait un effort pour accueillir
QaQaQaQaQaQaQaQatar et ses médis
répliquent aux critiques
que le Moyen-Orient est mimimimn
et que les journalistesétrangers
vraiment ce qui se passe
à la Coupe du monananananananan,
Radio-Canada, Doh